sécurité sociale qui est notre matelas
juste la parole et au président gilles
carez monsieur le président et cher
collègue monsieur le ministre des
finances
je veux vous féliciter pour votre
talents de prestidigitateur votre projet
de budget pour 2010 7 est un festival de
tour de passe-passe et d'astuces de
comptabilité tout ça pour essayer de
nous faire croire que le déficit public
va descendre en dessous de 3% l'an
prochain alors votre montage en trompe
l'oeil est simple d'un côté vous gonfler
artificiellement les recettes pour
l'année 2017 et de l'autre côté vous
repoussez les dépenses à l'année 2018 la
surestimation des recettes avec une
prévision de croissance de 1,5 pour cent
s'élèvent à plusieurs milliards d'euros
hello conseil des finances publiques que
préside le président de la cour des
comptes didier migaud conteste cette
prévision excessive et près de 10
milliards de dépenses sont reportés sur
2010 8
car la générosité du président hollande
pour les agriculteurs pour alstom pour
les fonctionnaires cette générosité
à quelques mois des élections
présidentielles
elle est financée à crédit elle va peser
sur les comptes publics
surtout à partir de 2018 ainsi le
déficit réel de la france
en 2017 sera très certainement
supérieure à 3%
ce n'est pas l'opposition qui vous le
dit c'est le haut conseil des finances
publiques lui qui est si sérieux alors
monsieur le ministre
permettez moi de vous demander
respectueusement
si vous n'êtes pas devenu
d'illusionniste en chef de la maison
bercy et monsieur le président comme il
me reste quelques secondes
je voudrais dire à madame touraine que
le rétablissement des comptes sociaux
est lié à la réforme des retraites
faites par françois fillon et
river en 2006 la parole est à monsieur
là
s'il vous plaît
avec la même énergie vous allez écouter
la réponse de monsieur michel sapin
miniser économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président car aise je vous ai connu
pendant de très bonnes zones nombreuses
années puisque vous siégez soit comme
président aujourd'hui soit comme
rapporteur général à la commission des
finances comme un homme modéré
raisonnable utilisant des arguments
rationnels et là vous nous démontrez
tout le contraire c'est dommage ça vous
va beaucoup moins bien
monsieur le président il vous plaît
allez viens on écoute un rapport à ce
sujet particulier dans ce budget pour
2010 est il n'y a aucun illusionnisme
dans ce budget 2010 est c'est un budget
sincère
c'est un budget qui continue une
politique de diminution des déficits
monsieur le président car aise si je
vous posais la question à quel niveau
avait vous laisser vous cette minorité
quand vous étiez majoritaire le déficit
de la france +2 5%
à combien allons-nous le porter grâce à
des efforts grâce à une croissance
supérieure à en dessous de 3% qui fait
le travail
nous qui a détérioré la france vous
voilà où est le sérieux
voilà vous devriez vous même accepté de
regarder la réalité en face et si je
devais regarder la dette la dette qui
vous préoccupent comme elle nous
préoccupe de combien de points par
rapport à la richesse nationale
la dette a augmenté sous votre
responsabilité en cinq ans de 25 points
de combien et elles augmenté sous notre
responsabilité de sept points qui donc
maîtrise adepte maîtrise l'avenir
prépare l'avenir de nos enfants
pas vous nous alors monsieur le
président vous demande vous qui aimez le
sérieux de ne pas perdre le vôtre
sous prétexte qu'il ya une sorte de
concours à celui qui d'ebay sera le plus
ces impôts et fait semblant de baisser
les dépenses entre des candidats à la
primaire sortez vous de ça c'est pas
parce que la primaire est là que vous
devez être primaire dans vos
raisonnements